hi i'm ryan wright
and i'm jerry and i'm veronica sixtos
welcome to reasons to see where we give
you reasons to see
and not to see hansel and gretel witch
hunters
so let's hang out
ryan's consensus you know what there are
a lot of reasons to see a hansel and
gretel witch hunters
there are a lot of reasons to see hansel
and gretel witch hunters
right off the bat i know i'm like the
only one that [ __ ] likes this movie
out of the world so i'm probably going
to be defending the [ __ ] out of it
jerry's consensus there are a few
reasons to see this movie there are a
few reasons to see hansel griddle witch
hunters
this is usually the movie where i'm in
your position everyone hates it i'm like
but it was fun
veronica's consensus so there's some
reasons to see hansel and gretel witch
hunters
there are some reasons to see hansel and
gretel witch hunters
i thought the movie was a lot of fun but
to be honest it's just not really my
style
reason to see number one production
design
i think the one thing we can all agree
on with this movie is it has good makeup
everything looked like a set to me but
that's why i liked it because it looked
like such a 90s movie to me
even with the cinematography going on
behind it i agree with the whole 90s
thing because
the first thing that came to mind was
like villains from power rangers
or like chucky the movie had like a lot
of cool gadgets throughout i like the
record player that was pretty [ __ ]
awesome
it's got sort of a steam punkiness to it
all the witch designs are really cool
like everything's got like a different
element it's based on
and stuff the witches were pretty scary
at times based off the makeup and
everything
and i thought the effects uh for edward
the troll were especially
yes that was all practical that was not
cgi i liked him
it's probably one of my favorite
characters the costumes there's a
good you know blend of the best of both
worlds with the
modern yes definitely got their black
leather thing going on
from the matrix they almost look like
they're from the future yeah reason to
see number two
the score i thought the score even when
i wasn't enjoying the movie i was like
this music is really cool and it is
helping it's
kind of got like a rock opera thing
going on about it it's got like a
sort of a rock industrial mixed with
some you know orchestral instruments
yeah i gotta be honest i don't remember
split decision number one the cast
i have a feeling this entire thing is
going to be a split decision review i
actually really enjoyed the cast i
thought jeremy renner was having a
really fun time to me
it looked like jeremy rider just showed
up on set and was like i'm gonna have a
lot of fun the girl
played gretel i thought she was [ __ ]
hot the villain i thought was really
good the girl from x-men i don't know
any of the cat's names besides jeremy
renner
what you said about jeremy renner i
didn't think he was having that much fun
really what are you talking about he
looked like he was having a blast
everybody in this movie to me felt like
everyone was all right
and then you know and then the only
people who seemed to get the idea were
peter stormer and famke jansen because
they were gnawing all over the scenery
and i was like thank you for having fun
i thought hansel and gretel both got the
idea did you think that would be
anything so i think it was part of their
character to be kind of
you know because you know why would she
want that well because
you know they were abandoned as children
they're probably these people who are a
little bit empty and cold and that's
kind of like their territory to make
that interesting
oh i thought they were very interesting
you know jared had a lot of his great
moments in there
he's just a badass not the whole thing
he's a great badass he's
he just kind of seemed grumpy cranky
yeah after the guy i did like her too
that's true after he got his dick wet
everything got a lot better for the guy
i will say that i i did like her i
thought that the girl who played
mina was good and she's gorgeous as far
as jeremy renner goes man
no no he was the [ __ ] he's like he's got
his shotgun and everything everything
about him was just so
he has a gun that's not a character i
feel the way you feel about jeremy
about gemma like she was she looked like
she was having
a little fun that's the weird thing for
me is even though i'm the guy who likes
this movie she was the one person to me
where i was like she's saying
every line the exact same way i took
that she had
like calm and composed and uh i don't
know
she had a little bit more personality to
me for whatever reason
than jeremy renner he was like one note
the entire time and i
i get i guess why it was one note the
entire time but she was one
well there are a lot of one note
characters i like the cast in this movie
though because i thought
he sounds like you don't think
everyone's on the same page i felt like
everyone was pretty much on the same
page for this movie
and the main villain to me i thought was
perfect in it because she was just the
right amount of scary not scary to the
point where i was actually terrified of
her but she was
scary enough for the characters for me
to be like how will they defeat this
person
how can they possibly beat this witch
this [ __ ] there's gonna be a lot of
those jokes yeah
earlier early 2000s rap censoring yeah
cause again she's chewing all over the
scenery like she's so
sniveling and over the top yeah but
that's what makes it great to have
jeremy renner
and gretel have both of them be like the
deadpan straightforward characters and
then to have the villain be the
over-the-top person they were the
straight characters i mean you always
have to have
the straight character everybody else
was pretty pretty goofy
i will say there were times where it
looked like hansel and gretel
were about to [ __ ] they're both really
attractive but
brother and sister that scene where they
fall into the witch later oh
hanzo oh greta oh thank god my sister
at least they felt something it was like
oh that's like you weren't
reporting this to you like i was like
okay all right i was like
like caressing her and everything like
yo it was weird but at least i was
feeling
something yeah she was on top of him
yeah didn't you have a boner
did he have a boner i remember him
having a boner that's a pretty long sex
scene
yeah edward was cool edward's badass guy
split decision number two
the humor there was there was
humor at first like 20 minutes i was
like okay the humor is not working for
me
editing of it the timing wasn't working
the guy who becomes like their assistant
for like the first like
30 minutes of the movie when he's like i
like their toys or something once he
made me laugh for some reason
all the humor was making me laugh
throughout the movie and the violence
was making me laugh i like jeremy renner
when he's hanging off the tree he's like
i'll get down later and you know
that was like mildly funny that was
pretty funny funny my favorite line
was don't eat the [ __ ] candy because
he has the sarcasm to him he's a
closed-off guy
with this sarcasm going on because
that's what close-up people are he was
just kind of cranky again
that's what i mean it seemed like jeremy
renner just showed up on set and was
having a good time being this guy to me
though like that cranky thing you're
talking about
i enjoyed that from him i thought that's
what made it funny he had some serious
mommy and daddy issues
yeah but you can still make that
interesting thank you veronica
thank you make the dialogue or something
like that make the humor more
humorous first it doesn't work but then
once you get a little bit of a laughter
like
ah that was kind of funny and then
eventually you're like
and it's like it was all kind of like a
chuckle
it's like a chucky's like him and then
it was always that it never built beyond
that everything was kind of like huh
that's that's amusing you know
maybe you have mommy and daddy issues
and that's why you didn't laugh
no i have a good family split decision
number three
the action this movie was so cool with
his action because the action to me
escalated it essentially went a scene or
two
action and then a scene or two gore and
violence action
and then the gore violence just kept
building and i thought they did some
very unique stuff i love that moment
where
he attaches that gadget to the witch's
room and then he's kind of like you know
water skiing through the forest and
all the gadgets they had i thought their
guns were cool the finale i thought was
awesome when they're [ __ ] up all the
witches the crossbow you know that i
thought that was a cool little adventure
they had going on
getting going just like i thought all
that was [ __ ] awesome
they're cool toys the scenes they get
used in are
all right nothing seems remarkable i
liked the fight scenes
like the witches were freaking they were
just whooping ass yeah the witches were
scary
and enough to be like yeah how do they
take them down and it was brutal and
violent like
flips i thought they had some great
chase scenes going on too throughout the
forest
and they managed to make a lot of great
chase scenes throughout it you know it's
like damn that's a pretty cool
chase and it made sense whenever they
were able to actually take them down
the troll fight was good too i will give
you i dug the troll where he's there's a
there's a troll
fight scene that's oh that's what i
loved about it because because it's an
r-rated movie
they were able to make a troll fight
scene finally where they show what a
troll can really do to a human
because most movies that are fantasy
based and have a troll
they're usually some giant and they
crush people but there's no blood and
guts
in this movie the troll kills like
several people but
all in a different kind of way but with
the same that scene
is red very gruesome yeah indeed not
every scene has that same level of
bravado
so i kind of feel like this whole movie
is like it's it wants to go to town and
arguably should go to town and it never
goes to town on anything
i gotta disagree because i thought the
gore in it was so cheesy
so over the top so visually effects over
the top that it's like you can't
possibly take this score seriously
no i don't want to i want it to be
[ __ ] wacky
but it was wacky throughout and they
have like seven to eight action scenes
in this movie
and i thought each action scene was
different enough to be an interesting
action scene it wasn't like on repeat
the whole time like how
bullet to the head looks like stupid
stallone man this movie made me want to
[ __ ] up some witches it starts off with
narration
ends with narration and then the all the
stuff in between the beginning
and and narration to me by the way the
narration seemed kind of pointless
all this stuff in between that was just
about the action and the adventure and
all the scenes
in it were kind of uninteresting that
did not contain action
but it was just like informative
exposition stuff going on but they
always hop
right back into the action right away
and to me there's like a good
i think it was there are a lot of action
scenes yeah but
i didn't feel like it's like quick let's
get to the action like abraham lincoln
vampire hunter is like no
abraham lincoln is more than two minutes
long i thought it's back to that
it was so much more boring than this
film i wish i could go inside your mind
and get the movie you saw
because that's all i wanted out of this
movie was was to have like a silly good
time watching people [ __ ] witches up
watching body parts fly everywhere
that's what it has
did you not see the same movie that we
it has all those things but not in a way
that's interest that i found interesting
at all and i
like i said so it has all those things
but for some reason you just don't like
it
see the thing is that it has those
things a bit
like there's that scene they show in the
trailer where they set up the wires and
then
those witches get shredded and that's
like a whoa that's a sweet moment
but it's not like all the action is on
that level of intensity i get the idea
of saving all the cool stuff for the
finale but give me a shred of something
else cool along the way to keep me
interested in it don't save all your
neat
camera tricks for the end you know in
the last minute
you know what i thought like this movie
was action packed throughout and
it delivers on the gore and violence
consistently
i guess so i agree [ __ ] you split
decision number four
the [ __ ] movie look to me it was just
a fun
90-minute 3d movie right it was like a
throwback to 90s movies
that's what i wanted it was that but
like i didn't get like a hint of sam
remy in there because if this was a sam
raimi movie they would it would have
been a lot more gross they would have
gone to town like you know
take drag me to hell's grossness throw
it in this movie that's a good fight
there's way more grossness in this movie
than trump
there is nothing there's so much there
are a couple eccentric
gore gags a troll just crushes a guy's
head
that's one moment drag me the hell is
filled with those this movie's filming
moments but i don't want to give them
all away
there's no there are a few there's
plenty if it was non-stop with that it
would have been
you would have gotten used to those
moments it's only 90 minutes
none of the gore is eccentric it was a
nice balance of action
and gore though because there's action
under score
and and it's it's not there's no real
violence it's just gore or action and it
is a great balance
both yeah no violence i'll give you this
yeah i want to call it
violent because it's so cheesy so over
the top
and looks so fake that you can't call it
because to me
when something's violent it's kind of
disturbing well i did have to cover my
eyes
for the trolls oh really that was cool
that is like a violent scene yeah
well the stomping i had to close my eyes
yeah i could understand see
it's always seems like it's trying to
get off the ground and it never quite
gets off the ground
i felt strongly about it because i felt
like everything about it was just some
bad cheese ball fest see that's the
thing is nothing was bad enough for me
to have fun with and nothing was good
enough for me to have fun with
everything just sort of felt like it was
in the middle and there would be a
couple moments where i'm like oh that's
cool
why can't we have more of that pretty
much throughout the movie i was a little
confused i was wondering
am i supposed to be taking this
seriously or i don't know that's so
that's why i
i'm kind of in the in between of liking
this i could give you that because there
are
uneven tonal shifts yeah but to me
that's why i like it because it's a bad
movie
like it's entertaining that may have
been my biggest problem
with this movie i kind of went in
expecting it to be the movie you got
which is big over the top you know 90 is
exploitation like just
bad and i don't feel that way about the
scenes that are not
that i don't have action in it i only
feel that way about the scenes i have
actually but i'm saying that because i
i felt that way because there are a lot
of action scenes
in it and because of that that's why i
have that feeling
are you not paying attention to the
movie i was paying attention to the
movie and i was sitting there going why
am i not more invested in this
because all the like even you said the
dialogue is like it's it's not
bullshitting you and it's not but it's
also not
trying either it's like here's the plot
we're not gonna dress it up in anything
that's fun to listen to like
see i like that because it was like yeah
just give us the information so we can
get back to the [ __ ] action that's
what i that's what i liked about get a
punch-up writer to make the information
at least
fun to listen to or make the characters
quirky or something like it's
because the movie doesn't have a whole
lot of personality which is a bummer
because this
a movie called hansel and gretel witch
hunter sounds ridiculous
and it should have a personality
shouldn't it like and i felt it did
though i
did too everything it's like one star
feels the way you do but
that's like very few people feel the way
i is like
it's like a guy who comes to your
costume party and he's got a rad
costume and all he talks about is the
weather outside like it's like he's got
nothing to say
he looks really cool but he's got
nothing to say to you and kind of like
you want to drink we're like what do you
wanna do you wanna hang why are you here
like
like really man you know i don't know
what so i agree with you ryan because
it is it's everything that you said it's
got the gore it's got the action
and with you i agree as well because you
know it's not
exactly my style and i also agree that
you know it was kind of um
in the in between most of the time it
was it wasn't everyone
wasn't in the same boat so which one of
us are you gonna have sex with wait a
minute
everything felt super predictable
of course in a way that wasn't i don't
know it's like at least trying to oh my
complaints are what i like about the
movie it's like
what you're saying is like i would say
those same exact things just with a
different tone
i would have to say watch it again all
right i'll take a look at it again i'll
take a second crackhead
go d-box i'll go d-box next time um be
like
we should hop box maybe it'll make the
movie better maybe
that's how you have to enjoy this movie
do you want to get dinner
after this yeah
oh just like your sister just like your
sister
subscribe subscribe click this button
and and tell us your reasons to see or
not to see hansel and gretel witch
hunters
yeah yeah yeah yeah tell us while you're
at it subscribe
yeah subscribe twice yeah get one for
your mom
subscribe unsubscribe and then subscribe
again yeah but don't forget the third
part because that would suck if you just
yeah
we need more subscribers yeah please
you